we're about to show you a clip from the
televised mental institution MSNBC here
is noted racist Joy Reed and she's upset
that people keep bringing up the George
Soros funded this D.A now before we show
you the clip I just want to be clear
George Soros did fund this D.A he has
also funded DA's in San Francisco Tessa
Bodine who destroyed San Francisco then
got recalled he also funded George
gascon formerly of San Francisco
destroyed that place now destroying Los
Angeles he has also funded DA's in
Philadelphia and in Chicago and in Tampa
and by the way that guy Ron DeSantis
removed him but somehow if you mentioned
that George Soros puts tons of money to
get DA's into these cities to then roll
back laws and then allow criminals out
on the streets and then we know what
happened in all these blue cities
somehow you're being racist yeah
Tracy Walder last award to you then on
this the fact that they keep throwing
George soros's name we've talked a lot
on the on in our show meetings is it
definitely feels like a dog whistle that
is dangerous
it absolutely feels like a dog whistle
that's dangerous look most of these
groups of Oath Keepers Boogaloo boys
proud boys they all subscribe to what
you you are all referring to as the
great replacement Theory which is that
idea that the majority of the white
population is is being replaced and this
is why we see these spikes in in racism
these spikes in anti-Semitism is because
they are ascribing to this belief and
it's stoking this this Division I mean
Trump has for multiple years actually
now has called for a Civil War and I
think that's really what he's inferring
when he does that and that's why we're
playing whack-a-mole essentially because
a lot of these online threats
and Republicans are letting him do it
and the Republican party is letting him
do it they stand by and as if that's
okay it's embarrassing it's yeah yeah
you're embarrassing lady whoever you are
these people are so embarrassing the
spikes in racism and the spikes and
attacks on say Jews and Asians in New
York it's funny are they white
supremacists doing these things no it's
virtually all black people
that's just a fact that's not me being
racist that's just telling you what's
happening watch anytime an Asian woman
is just mauled on the street in
Chinatown in New York City or when they
go into Brooklyn and just attack a bunch
of Orthodox Jews it's not a bunch of
white supremacists with maganuses and
flags Like Jesse Smollett would have you
believe in the media would love and
guess what if that was happening you
would know about it because the media
would be going all in on it right it
would be a freaking uh bukaki of uh
information
ah
it was a lot it was a lot the point is
that Alvin brags these DA's they
incentivize all of these racist attacks
because they are soft on crime right
once you say to people ah you know
occasionally you're allowed to just you
know I don't know rape someone in a
vestibule if they're trying to go into
their apartment or just punch a random
person or push them into a Subway
etc etc and instead of call making that
a felony will actually downgrade that to
a misdemeanor which this guy has done on
a crazy amount of cases well then bad
guys start doing more bad things
thank you
[Music]
foreign